so my name is Pat Helen I work at
Salesforce and this is not about
Salesforce stuff I've been doing
distributed systems transactions
databases implementing them scalable
multiprocessor with Dennis Allison back
twenty seven years ago I was working
with him but I've been doing this for 40
years and so as I said I'm currently and
I was I've done work at tandem computers
was at Microsoft for many years at
Amazon for a while and now at Salesforce
and this particular talk is just one of
the things that I think about right and
I called it mind your state for your
state of mind
basically the evolution evolutions of
computation and storage lead to
interesting challenges and again these
are just my personal observations I have
a whole collection of papers that I
write about just a random philosophical
junk I think of with respect to
distributed systems I actually think in
the paper for this I described it as a
ruminations which is this wonderful
concept of you know thinking this thing
over and over again so this is a paper
it was published in just a month ago in
communications of the ACM and so you're
free to go look it up and it's online
and it's in hardcopy
so I'm gonna cover a bunch of things I'm
gonna do an introduction I'm going to
talk about what's this state stuff we
always talk about state we talk about
stateless and no one that I know
actually has a cogent explanation of
what that is and let's see if you think
this is a way of thinking about it that
makes sense we're gonna talk about the
evolution of durable state semantics
we'll talk about session state semantics
and transactions something near and dear
to my heart because I worked on it for a
number of years identity immutability
and scale some example application
patterns and then we're gonna have a
conclusion so I'm gonna start back and
talk about the way computing was when I
had hair I honestly had hair at some
point in time before I ended up dying it
transparent and so I want to look back
storage has evolved when I was starting
out in this the only storage you had was
directly attached
to the one and only one computer you
were using okay there eventually came
along these sheared appliances called a
SAN or a storage area network which
offered some high-performance stuff and
the ability for multiple computers to
whack on some shared storage storage
clusters contained in a network which
was sort of like a sand but a little
more loose in the way it was built and
even rest API is fascinate me the whole
representational state transformation
nature of using HTTP in order to make
something look like storage even if it's
computation and so there's this really
interesting thing about REST API z--
over microservices computing has evolved
back in the day there was a single
process well maybe two or three in the
same computer if you got lucky right and
that was called a mainframe region at
first if you were you know familiar with
IBM stuff and then you got multiple
processes in the same server
I remember how cool it was to start
doing our pcs across all a little tiny
cluster in the same room that was like a
miracle to be able to do that kind of
work then services and service-oriented
architecture and I did some
presentations and talks I never quite
turned it into a paper of what I call a
fiefdom which was an independent today
we would call it a service and how you
would talk across that and that whole
service-oriented architecture and how
did you scale with that is a very
interesting thing but that broke apart
the transaction says that we were
familiar with having we'll talk about
that now we talked about micro services
and those micro services have little or
no state they come they go they're
flighty but they offer some real
advantages now Computing's use of
storage has evolved we used to have
direct file i/o and we used this thing I
call careful replacement for
recoverability we will dig into careful
replacement and gory details so don't
get too stressed if it doesn't make
sense yet but the careful replacement
variations are number one because what
you're writing might trash the previous
value you should put it somewhere else
before you write it where you're going
to eventually have it land that's the
first form of careful replacement and
then the second form is that the client
can interrupt a sequence
of Rights so plan carefully to have a
partial sequence by the time you try to
do recovery those are the two things
we're gonna talk about thematically now
transactions came along and I've been
working on transactions you know since I
was working on databases but I owned and
shipped the stuff for tandems non-stop
transaction engine in I was working on
that from 82 through 91 and how do you
build logging in recovery and high
performance and making it work but
transactions were implemented careful
replacement for the app they dealt with
a bunch of junk underneath and the
hardware in the system itself so the app
didn't have to and made it easy for it
well the comment is I should explain who
tandem was so they were started in 74
and kind of eventually petered out over
the late 90s but I left in 1990 and you
would get to 216 computers in one big
system and the actual measured installed
base over over 4,000 customers which you
can read about in Jim Gray's paper why
computers fail the measured mean time
between failure of the system was 11
years and there were a number of sites
where nobody worked at the company
anymore since the system had gone down
because it was designed to handle one of
the computers failing and the rest of
them continuing on so I ended up
building the logging and recovery part
of the database that made the entire
system go so here you are with and it
was running federal funds transfers and
stock exchanges and hospitals and all
the things that cared a lot about high
reliability would use the tandem system
and it was transactional
enterprise-grade and highly available
with what we were building and a lot of
fun I learned a lot there over a decade
almost a decade the u.s. was not
anything familiar it was completely
separate the application programming
interface was not and I believe over
time it stopped being an important
player in the industry because in the
late 70s if you
by that piece of hardware you could
afford 50 people with white lab coats to
program it because the software was far
cheaper than the big expensive systems
of the day right and so you could do
your customized app and there were some
ISPs that did the apps but they weren't
enough to keep the business going
so as the turnkey software packages came
they didn't run on it and that's how
come you don't hear so much about it
anymore
did that make sense okay but it was
actually not that hard to program to so
it was just kind of a unfortunate
catch-22 that happened was when I was
talking to Computer History Museum about
trying to preserve some of them they had
no concept content was why it was
significant it he it kind of happens
that way yeah it was it was the here you
want your bank account to run off oh it
was designed for that and it succeeded
in that and I'm very proud of the work
and college at the same time the
California Department of Motor Vehicles
got a 65 million dollar tandem I never
never got it to work they went they
never got remember the fight I knew so
let me keep going yeah if you don't go
ok ok so implement a careful replace
transactions implement that careful
replacement and the sands implemented
careful replacement but stateful
two-tier and interior transactions and
doing that came along now and you ended
up with key value storage typically
atomic key value so we see this today
you can do one keys value update in a
transaction but not many of them because
of the way they're distributed and
finally rest put invokes the app code of
that resource who knows what that does
to the affected state when you call with
an e put with an HTTP with the rest
stuff so there's challenges in modern
micro service base apps today the micro
services power many scalable apps pools
of equivalent services incoming requests
are load balanced this is a direct image
off the PDF for a 2007 paper from Amazon
called dynamo which I helped work on
dynamo back in the day and so was part
of the initial design but what you see
is you see the the requests
coming in and they're they're
load-balanced out and you do page
rendering and then it comes back and
then they're load-balanced out they do
aggregator services and they come back
and then there's a request routing and
their load balanced out and behind it
you see in this picture four different
stores working for to support four
different service pools okay and so this
is the way Amazon was building in this
way it's still building it okay in the
front-end part of what you see in eread
ecommerce retail is typically done this
way with many different kinds of stores
to support many different kinds of pools
of micro services micro services support
many operational needs they support
health media to deploy with Canaries
rolling upgrade sensitive to fault zones
and fault tolerance so let's talk about
that for a second the term canary comes
back to someone going into a coal mine
and taking a little yellow bird with
them because if there was methane gas
and the bird fell over
you got the heck out of the key out of
the mine and you lived because you
brought that early warning system when
you roll out across a hundred different
servers so you have a hundred different
servers that are working on the same
stuff and you roll it out that's cool
what you want to do is roll it out to
maybe five of them and then see what the
hell happens right and then if that
works then you start rolling keep
rolling about that's called Canaries and
doing automated Canaries in health media
to deploy is a way of a formal way of
saying I'm gonna do it as long as
everything's healthy I'm gonna roll out
the new version of this thing as long as
it's healthy all of this is facilitated
by microservices rolling upgrade I'm
gonna roll do my rolling upgrade but
what I don't want to do is I don't want
to bring down too many things to kill a
fault zone or I'm going to count on
doing the ones within a fault zone not a
cross fault zone so I can't handle the
failure and then fault tolerance if
things are dying you always things can
die while you're rolling out durable
state is usually not kept in micro
services you go elsewhere to get to that
durable state in this picture here you
see these things right here which are
the services going down to get the
dynamo instances or going down to get
Amazon s3 or going down to get storage
in an ACK in a back-end database and
that's the way you do it you don't put
the state in the micro service because
they're flighty and they die right you
can't effectively update that state
across it if I have a hundred micro
services I can't get all of them to know
the new state at
comically it's a real interesting
challenge you have to so you push it
elsewhere and then versions are cached
now you have to talk about staleness of
cached versions sometimes read through
requests to durable state access
information that's not in the micro
services okay so we're just getting
started
this is that was the introduction let's
talk about what this state stuff is
durable state and session state right so
in durable state what do you have is
stuff that gets remembered across
requests and persists across failures so
that's durable state it persists if
something fails what is it
database data file system files he
values caches there's a lot of things
you can put it in their cache is kind of
iffy about whether it meets that
persistence criteria how is it updated
single updates or transactions or
distributed transactions or careful
replacement which we'll talk more about
do you use messaging semantics to get
asynchronous update of stuff can you
read your rights consistently so this is
gonna be a big deal I write something
and I go to read do I get it back or do
I get the old version back okay we'll
talk about that weekly consistent stores
and and/or caching each make read your
rights a challenge session state it
session state by definition isn't gonna
survive a failure right but it's the
stuff that gets remembered across
requests in a session but not across
failures so session state exists within
the endpoints associated with a session
multiple operation transactions are a
form of session state what do I mean I
pay on the left says begin transaction
he talks to app B may be the database
across a session chatters five times
that says commit the transaction okay
that's an example of multi operation
transactions session state is hard to do
when the session smears across the
services in that micro-service thing I
can do a request and I go to server 3 I
could do another request and the load
balancer sends me to server 7 it's hard
to have session state when that occurs
typical state of the art with load
balancers is you have affinities ation
which means I'll usually send you back
to the same micro service instance I did
before but if I don't feel like it good
luck
I'm going somewhere else so it's hard to
do session state when you do that data
on the inside versus data on the outside
redux okay so I wrote this paper in 2005
which says when you unlock stuff it's
different so data on the inside is
inside the database data on the outside
is not inside the database well what's
different about it inside you get
classic relational data it's about
values it's about values within cells
right it's about holding that still this
is so much a belief of mine that that
when I was asked to name I have a column
in communications of the ACM about that
I can write there actually wish I would
write another couple this year because I
haven't done as many and so the the
column I picked was called escaping the
singularity it's not your grandmother's
database anymore why because to do this
relational junk you have to bring
everything to what looks like a single
place and you have to use transactions
to make it look like a single time and
when everything is still and everything
is here then relational algebra works
okay so that isn't true so much anymore
so you get two data on the outside where
you have messages and files and events
and key value pairs and unlock data not
stored in a classic database and it my
observation is whenever I push it out of
the database I have to put identity on
it now maybe I've got an optional
versioning that's cool but it's got an
identity and that identity is what how I
make things work and I actually have a
paper in edit to be coming out soon
called identity by any other name which
talks about all the ways in which
identity permeates our environment
outside outside data is immutable each
file message key has a unique identifier
it may be a URL or a key or something
else it may be implicit on a session it
may be implicit within the environment
but it has some identity and then within
that you have immutable data potentially
versions but each of those is a sequence
of different
immutable data items and I have another
paper called immutability changes
everything from a few years back
so let's talk about the evolution of
durable state semantics so care for
replacement of disk blocks back when I
was a kid you had to worry about the
following thing if you went to write a
disk block that disk block had the old
value and then in the middle of the
right it had trash and then in the at
end of the right it had the new value
and if you had a power failure during
that window and you tried to read the
block you could get back in neither
there were times when you would get back
neither the new nor the old value and
that's kind of annoying you have to plan
for that you had to think about that you
had to work it right and so that was
just annoying so you would do things
like here's file 1 and I've got version
1 at the end there in orange and then
file one would be trashed and then I get
version 2 and that was kind of what life
was like to update a block so you could
do care for replacement for single block
writes with mirrors what you would do is
you'd write the new value in to some
other place or another parallel file and
only after the new value is safe you
override it so writing the tail of the
log into a carefully in tamir disk
imagine that the tail of the log the
last set of transactions you committed
is in the left half of that block that
went through version one to version two
so if that trashed it you would end up
losing stuff you said was to be kept and
that's something you want to avoid so
here you've got two versions and you
write version two and then you write
version two but there is no window in
there where at least one of the versions
could not be read off of one of the two
okay and so that works for mirrored
blocks works for the mirrored tale of
the log that's how I built the tail of
the log at the tandem system so as to
survive the failures with well you're
trashing the blocks and so you could do
careful blocks when you have single
block rights with non mirrors what you
would end up doing is you would write
version 1 you would write it in a
separate block then you once it was in
the separate block that you go write it
back to where it was and then you could
continue to reuse that second volume to
version 2 of that so that technique of
being very thoughtful about how and
where is an old
Niq we don't have to do that anymore
with disk blocks because the controllers
have got batteries there's a whole bunch
of reasons why we'd have to worry about
it but that concept of carefully putting
one foot on the ground and then another
foot on the ground and then another foot
on the ground to cross the river is an
important concept in making the systems
work
careful replacement for record writes so
if I'm gonna do a careful replacement
record writes say I do updates to
records in a pre sequel database if I
was gonna do that that needed careful
ordering setting aside the disk block
issue so I might have to update one
record say record X before updating
record Y how come because if I could see
record X but not wise change I could put
it back together but if I saw wise
change and not X's change it trashed
everything and so I would have to be
thoughtful about the ordering of
updating records so here record 1 and
then I can recover after a crash but in
that case where I update you know record
Y first before record X I can't put it
together and there's an example with
this an example is an application queue
so many of our systems have queuing you
see this in Kafka and you see this an
other you know things that are being
built today the queue describes I intend
to do this and then you do it and then
that's cool because you can restart
Andry drive it and it's idempotent and
restartable transactions and careful
replacement
I loved transactions I still love
transactions they bundle and solve care
for replacement so all that stuff with
the disks all that stuff with handling
multiple changes out in storage they
deal with it you just say begin do a
bunch of junk end and you're happy right
multiple app records can be updated in a
single transaction and it's going to be
atomic they the databases make that
storage stuff that storage careful
replacement just not a problem it's
magic it's taken care of by the plumbing
underneath you working across time like
workflow if I'm going to be doing
something to get this job done and then
waiting for some other thing to tell me
to do the next step and waiting for
another thing to tell me to do the next
step that requires me to be thoughtful
about how my data in my application is
managed to move
state 1 2 maybe an hour later I find out
some changes happen I'm gonna do state 2
and that work overtime is is really a
challenging and that's very important
with careful transactional replacement
work over space if I'm gonna work on
this computer system and it's gonna talk
to that computer system I'm typically
gonna have to do the first step here
commit then send a message then it gets
there and I get that second step do
commit and send a message back then I
come back and I do the third step and
commit and do a message that comes back
there is an observation which is that
when you break time or you break space
you if you break space you break time
let me put it that way if you break
space you break time and so that's cool
we just have to get used to it and
figure out how to move it forward leads
us to message semantics I want to point
out this careful replacement it's deja
vu all over again as Yogi Berra said so
messaging semantics transactional
messaging is cool right the first
transaction includes a desire to send
and then transactional updates happen
automatically so here I am I'm doing
transaction t1 and I'm writing some of
my local data W X Y Z and I'm gonna send
a message to that other guy and then
that transaction atomically consumes the
incoming message and that consumption is
atomic so here I am and I'm going to
consume that message and it's gonna
change ABCD in transaction t2 on the
other system you can support exactly
once messaging with this okay a
committed desire to send causes one or
more sends where I retry and Toole
acknowledged so I'm sending a bunch of
things and then at least once Adam gets
through now over on the right hand side
transaction t2 it makes sure that the
process is at most once it this is
normal this is cool if we have
relatively static systems it's really
cool if you have a scalable system with
a whole bunch of shards and junk moves
around and the identity is challenging
it can be hard because you have to
remember the messages you've processed
at some level right you know TCP does it
with byte stream ordering and
sliding-window protocol somehow you have
to do this it has some relationship that
relationship is a scalene
how do you remember the messages that
I'm filtering infrared at most once
delivery
I got a detect the duplicates how long
do I remember what if my destination
splits how do I deal with all those
issues mostly that stuff is nascent and
people don't figure it out and it goes
wrong when things change a lot of times
okay next concept is kind of fun read
your rights do I read my rights or don't
I read my rights so it used to be back
in the day if you wrote something you
could read it go figure
strange concepts write linearizable
stores offer read your rights so what
does that mean it means every change to
that object or that block or that
whatever happens in a linear order I
make a change then I make another change
then I make another change and each time
I make a change I can see the stuff that
was written before so linearizable means
occasionally delay for a long time when
the server is sick okay what do I mean
by that okay when you see if I have that
what do I mean by linearizable causes
delays it turns out that it's very hard
to have a perfect notion of an order
under failures unless I'm working it
across multiple systems and if one of
those systems is slow because it's doing
garbage collection or just because right
the whole world doesn't slow down if you
look at the responsiveness of servers
it's usually really really really good
until it's not and when it's not it's
not okay it's slow you can see a typical
server go away for a minute just because
it's garbage collecting or just because
something stuttered and you know things
like you lost a packet in TCP can cause
a while to recover so the question
becomes how fast does it happen but
linearizable meaning if I write
something and I see a value I'm gonna
see the next value I'm not gonna see
something old I'm not gonna see
something blue I'm not gonna see
something borrowed I'm gonna see that
old value making sure that happens
requires that sometimes things will go
slow and you see that constantly so if I
have a linearizable store is it going to
give me fast predictable reads no
because I can't necessary
get to the thing to find the latest
value I may be stalled behind it and you
see this in a lot of stores will it give
me fast predictable rights no but by
golly if I write something and I go to
read it will I see it you bet I will see
it okay and that's the linearizable
nature of it nonlinear risible stores do
not offer read your rights nonlinear
izybelle is no guarantee that a right
will update all the replicas it might
read an old value so reading and writing
have a very consistent SLA why because
you can skip over sick or dead servers
so that paper I talked about about
Dynamo from Amazon in 2007 it was OS di
2007 paper it's really really an
interesting read if you are going to
write three replicas in the Dynamo store
in one of the three year targeting is
down or slow or whatever you just keep
going right and on another one if you're
gonna go read from one of those servers
you go and read and you keep going till
you find one sometimes you said you can
configure I'm going to read to to
minimize the chance that I get a stale
thing because you can tell this that the
ordering of them this is a newer versus
older one and so you will sometimes get
the wrong value define wrong you will
sometimes get not the recent value not
the latest value read but by golly
you'll get something fast when you're
right and by golly you'll get something
fast when you read and that right
doesn't get lost because it's on three
servers and it will eventually settle
out but somebody can see the stuff in
between sometimes so these are
trade-offs to talk about nonlinear
reservoirs do not offer read your rights
there's no guarantee your right will
update all the replicas you might get a
null value reading and writing or fast
skip over sick and dead servers so a
nonlinear as herbal store fast
predictable read yes fast predictable
right yes read your rights not promising
pretty much but no I once and one though
cached data offers scalable read
throughput with great SLA s key value
pairs are in many computers they're
updated with versions a read hits one of
the computers and returns one of the
versions so if I have a scalable cache
can I get fast predictable reads I can
get fast predictable reads and I can get
it for more and
more and more reads per second if I add
more and more servers so I can scale the
heck out of it right can I have fast
predictable writes no it can take a long
time for the new version of the thing in
the cache to get everywhere
can I read my rights No so there are
different stores for different uses
is it ok to stall on read is it ok to
stall on right
is it ok to return a stale version you
can't have everything and so Peter
Bayless has this really great blog post
called linear eyes ability versus
serializability that's really fun
immutability a rock a solid rock to
stand on sometimes we can store
immutable things so if you look for it
many app patterns can create many
immutable things 128-bit UUID is a great
example of identity that doesn't collide
if I store immutable things it can
change the behavior of the store you
can't get an old version of something
where there's not an old version there's
one version and if you hit something
like dynamo and it can't find the one
and only one version says well let me
try the next server and so you get an
answer pretty fast because it keeps
going fast and when it finds it it's
fast but it's never wrong because
there's only one answer for that key so
that's a huge observation that makes the
system behave differently so if I've got
a linearizable store all of this stuff
you've seen scalable scalable scalable
but if I have read your rights for
immutable and I'm storing immutable I
get ya sure it works nonlinear as well
though it works scalable cache it works
so the nonlinear risible store to hold
immutable data for that purpose has
phenomenal characteristics it's fast to
write it's fast to read it's fast and
you get the one and only one answer so
the read your rights question kind of
stops being an interesting question so
there's interesting opera you know
options for applications nonlinear
resonance tours give fast and
predictable writes and reads and
scalable cache gives you lots of fast
and predictable reads holding immutable
data is a huge benefit in designing your
app we don't talk about this enough we
don't teach people about this enough it
makes it just a very different behavior
out
your system and I have a paper out there
which is in communications the ACM
called immutability changes everything
which talks about a lot of these
characteristics session state semantics
and transactions same process different
process back in a day the database
system was a bunch of libraries in your
app ok that was the way it started out
and then used to run in the same process
and sometimes you'd load multiple apps
in it then you started peeling it out
and putting it into a different process
and you used a connection in a TCP
connection to connect them and you know
the session had session state describing
users transactions apps being run
current state you know each process in
the session has information about it
with a session state and the session
state is on each side of the connection
from the database to the app that's
interacting with the database later
still after we pulled them into
different processes we start putting
them into different processes on
different servers that was actually a
pretty straightforward transformation
once we had them on different processes
on the same server and sessions and
session state made that work to split
them across a small cluster and that was
really hard though in so many ways I
remember doing it was a big fight to get
it done so steep phille sessions and
transactions stateful sessions were the
natural outcome of shared processes you
knew who you were talking to you because
you used to be in the same process you
knew who you were talking to so you can
remember stuff about the other guy so
you can do transactions and you could
chatter within the transaction I could
say begin transaction here's some stuff
get some answer here's some stuff get
some answer here's some stuff get some
answer commit and that worked pretty
well set stateful sessions worked well
for classic service-oriented
architecture we don't talk enough still
about classic service-oriented
architecture I want to write a paper
about it I haven't yet but it was
typically there was no transaction
across that boundary you've had a
two-tier environment typically around a
classic database but it was that
distrusting boundary and services are
about trust and that Trust who you would
just kind of say forget it this is my
enterprise data you're not coming in
unless I inspect your message and decide
I like you and all that kind of stuff
right so Stifel sessions meant the
application can do multiple interactions
within a transaction
in many circumstances the rich and
complex transactions could occur over
into your environments and even across
multiple back-end databases so I was
chief architect at Microsoft where I
think on Microsoft transaction server
didn't like the name okay but it was
really how do I build stateful into your
component based applications and run
them across multiple back-end databases
and we shipped that in 96 in 1996 and so
you see a client coming in talking to a
pay which is talking to a B which is
talking to database one and he's got
enough session state to manage the
transaction there but even more
interesting the client two can come in
and talk to AB C which talks to D and E
which talked to two different databases
and that meant you had to do distributed
transactions across the backend and and
there were advantages to this right but
distributed transactions are sometimes
brittle and so I wrote up paper in 2007
called life beyond distributed
transactions which talks about the
brittleness of that and concerns
transactions sessions and microservices
Micra services stink when it comes to
sessions date why because you might get
load balance to the next guy and so
you're not talking to the guy you were
talking to before or he can die it's not
they're not big and heavyweight the way
they were right usually they go back to
the same micro service instance but
there's no session stay because it
doesn't always work session state is
needed to create transactions that span
multiple requests if you can't span
multiple requests you can't do a
transaction across multiple requests it
doesn't work that way that transaction
identity needs to be there to do the
two-phase commit so micro services are
typically a one store request you can
read a bunch of junk that's not
transactional e consistent that's okay
right but if you want to change
something each change is one single
change atomic at a time right and so
that ends up being not two-phase commit
and so you end up being able to do stuff
but now you're back in the world where
that key value store I'm doing careful
replacement that old care for
replacement AK you know thing comes back
I'm gonna do record I'm gonna do key X
before I do key Y in order to make it
all work micro services are worth the
restrictions though
fail-fast load-balanced health media to
deploy with Canaries rolling up grades
fault tolerance and more the software
engineering
advantages and the operational
management deployment aspects mean that
they're not going away the app developer
is gonna deal with not having
transactions because this is better to
have little pieces of development and
little and things to manage and
deployment so it's just a change that
we're in the midst of it's not your
grandmother's transaction any more
transactions today with micro services
only work on a single call to the store
as the application micro services scale
more instances are made as micro
services composed they call each other
scalable stores fine transactions across
multiple identities distributed
transactions across store instances
that's challenging and you end up with
this interesting of scalable linearize
ability per identity read your rights
scaleable nonlinear eyes ability per
identity read one or more old versions
when you have a nonlinear izybelle store
and you read what you're saying is I'm
gonna get any version you got with a
probability stick that is heavy towards
the last one and that's fine if you're
using it correctly we'll talk about
usages of that identity immutability and
scale
what's identity each identity is
represented by some numbers some strings
some URI some whatever right I don't
have a problem with how you do it which
is why that next paper is identity by
any other name it can reference
something that's immutable like New York
Times October 9th 2002 17 San Francisco
Bay Area edition that's immutable it is
what it was it was what it is it's gonna
be that forever that identity can
reference something that changes over
time today's New York Times changes
every day okay actually changes based
upon the region of the country you're in
each version of the identity is
immutable a change makes a new version
that's cool so you're flipping the
pointer from the the changeable identity
into the unn
changeable identity and every day you
flip that pointer to a new immutable
identity but that's separate from the
fact that that new immutable identity
can always go get the same bits the same
images the same everything creating an
identity for the immutable version is
really useful because I can cash I can
copying I can reference they're not
subject to ambiguity where there's
ambiguity is the mapping from today to
the underlying version but that's
typically much easier to manage when
you're just dealing with an identity so
this picture here denotes a linear
version history I go from the top circle
to the second circle to the third circle
I have a sequence of things and each
circle is dependent upon the previous
circle the version history might be a
dag so here I see that I've got multiple
parents in some of these pictures
sometimes and so that's a nonlinear
izybelle history of things where
independent
updates happen separately and concurrent
versions can come back together
representing a fork in history so cross
identity relationships using careful
replacement across identities is a
tried-and-true technique if I find
something with identity a and I go from
version W to version X that's great if I
find something from identity B I can go
from version Y diversions II so here I
am in a linearizable world and I changed
W to Z X and I change Y to Z and I do
them in that order and then there's no
ambiguity but it's also the case that
any and every time I say version Z of
identity B I'm going to see version X of
identity a I never have the case that
version Z of identity B exists without
that so the windows of time were you
know each window of time where B is V Z
also shows a as V X careful replacement
is predictable over linearizable stores
I will never see version Z of B unless I
can read version X of a that's
predictable careful replacement over a
nonlinear risible store will behave
really wonky you may write a version of
some ID and read the ID and get the
older version cash stores will behave
unpredictably so here what I have is I
have identity a on
left with two replicas and identity
beyond the right with two replicas so I
update identity a to have an on replica
two to have you know the version W and
then over here I update identity be on
replica one to have version Z and that
squirts its way over to the other side
so now replica two knows version Z and
that squirts from a two replicas to two
replicas one so version W is overrun for
identity a and then he crashes so now he
crashes so now when I go to read I see
this wonky thing where versions see Z
exists on over on the right and I've got
and I don't in that window of time but I
don't yet have W so violated to my
consistency constraints no matter how
you deal with this if you have nonlinear
izybelle stores and you can't read your
rights you can't do any form of care for
replacement because it's gonna be wonky
there are windows that will be wonky the
only thing you probably also can't do is
test it because you won't find those
windows very effectively I think I
screwed it up yes you're correct
I can't my reading glasses aren't on so
I can't come yes I think I screwed it up
I have to fix it
thank you okay so care for replacement
will be buggy over a nonlinear as
opposed stores I'm sorry for the
confusion okay how append blurs identity
this one is a mind mess this is fun
okay HDFS and other big data system
except rights to append to a big file so
I'm running an HDFS you're right you're
just slapping new messages new new
writes on to the end of this big file
that's what HDFS does and HDFS is
designed to have three replicas so you
set up a block and if you write to the
first block then it will take the write
and log it locally in its durable store
and then it'll send it to the second
replica who will put it in a block and
right into its store and then ascend it
to the third replica who'll write it and
put it in a store and they come back and
then they say that was a delicious right
he was great
I'm happy in the new right the next
thing okay and so HDFS deliberately
restricts a
go writer per file it's a conscious
choice they make predictable and
repeatable replica data takes careful
design GFS Google file system preceded
HDFS and it allowed multiple writers to
a file and it had fixed size blocks as
HDFS does failures in race conditions
sometimes allow different data per
replicas what huh so I have multiple
writers from two different processes
hitting the primary and he's going to
take one you're gonna write it and then
you're gonna send it to the message to
the secondary but before that message
gets there the primary dies okay and so
now the second client says dude you're
dead and he goes and he talks to the
secondary and he writes there first and
that right from the first client got to
the first replica and didn't get to the
second and there's no protection for
that in GFS and that's documented in a
in a column with Kirk McKusick
and trying to remember the name a so it
was a communications primary what no
wasn't Sam it was Shawn it was Shawn
Quinlan and it's it's in communications
of the ACM he talks about it in a
conversation which great it's
fascinating stuff
now I worked at Microsoft on cosmos
which is of the plumbing under being not
cosmos DB that's being advertised now
but cosmos it's that there's two
different products and it takes multiple
writers but what it does is it actually
has variable length blocks
they're called extents in that but
they're variable length blocks you say
how the heck is a variable length block
correlated with precise imaging of these
replicas under failures if you do a
write from this and you got multiple
writers fighting to that to get to that
primary good okay and the first first
one gets and he writes it and then he's
now he crashes and so this master which
is called the CSM detects that he's gone
and he says to the secondary how much
data do you have in that last block in
that plastic stent oh you've got you
know 748 bytes great we're gonna take
seven and 48 bytes we're gonna make that
block be seven or forty
eight blocks will truncate it and now
you can talk to the secondary and the
tertiary and then we'll keep going so
when that primary comes back up anything
he has for that particular block of the
file in excess of the amount that was
decided and recorded in the master is
discarded and so now the file is
pristine and perfect even when competing
with multiple writers even with fighting
that so HDFS made a wonderful legitimate
choice six lengths blocks easier to deal
with single writer great it's a fine
legitimate choice cosmos made the the
choice of multiple writers but we're
gonna deal with the garbage of variable
length blocks which means every time you
want to do a bio a index you have to
scratch your head and look up this stuff
and figure it out so it's just
but the reason I'm raising this is
because the notion of consistence append
and how do you do that consistently is a
very complex area in all of these things
and and this is stuff we have to think
about as systems builders so a pen to
file X Y Z does not have adequate
identity that's this other interesting
thing append doesn't have identity the
identity is assigned by the primary and
when you get into failure modes of the
primary replica of the data block data
the the data file right how do you
manage that
and so assigning the append location
means right appends may stall this whole
thing is a big stall and you're just
dealing with the stalls you want to talk
about not having predictable response
time these guys are scratching their
heads to go through all sorts of
coordination to clean it up and that's
fine these are batch systems there's
nothing wrong with that but it's not the
thing you want to have your user waiting
to do your online shopping for okay
that's kind of where I'm going with this
so stalls on big data pens are just fine
because they're for batch so again I'm
not I love what's being done it has huge
utility and it's great but it's
different so let's look at some
application example patterns and tie all
of this together
careful replacement over key value if I
have a big ginormous key value store and
I'm gonna be doing a workflow and I am
going to be
making promises to these other computer
systems I probably don't want wonky
nonlinear Aiza behavior I probably want
it to stall if it needs to stall to make
sure that I get the right behavior even
if some servers crash and they were
scratching their head for a minute or
two to figure it out I mean you need to
realize it typically takes like upwards
of a minute for a cluster to decide that
servers dead by golly he's dead I'm not
gonna talk to him anywhere what am i
doing he's gone you look up and you
figure oh here's what I do and he's gone
and so if you can't tell he's gone then
you can't figure out how to respond to
him being gone so you can build scalable
applications over key value stores but
you probably want linearizable behavior
with read your rights so again there's
this workflow here and you probably want
that to finish in the right time windows
ok transactional blobs by ref let's give
you an example of something a little
different see I got a transactional
system but people are doing things like
putting out big documents in it you
don't want to put that in your
relational system it's a pain in the
tush right it's not really good for it
right so you want to have that big
system and the blobs are correlated with
relational data so you want to put
immutable blobs out in that nonlinear
risible store cuz it's fast so the app
says I want to run a transaction then
I'm gonna write these three things out
and then I wanted to do another
transaction to say they're there ok
now the database itself will sometimes
stall although they get a lot of
engineering to avoid the stalls they you
don't very often but the nonlinear as
able store will add to it will won't add
to it because of the nonlinear risible
behavior but I'm putting immutable stuff
so it's going to be crisp and
transactionally good
so the blobstore can be implemented with
many commodity servers you don't want to
delay humans are waiting for it and the
nonlinear as well store has excellent
slis
ok so that's why read your rights is
immutable in this picture this one's fun
ecommerce shopping cart each shopping
cart is for a separates customer
nobody's excited about transactions
across carts nobody wants that right to
heck with that and there's customers are
very unhappy if the shopping cart stalls
there's measured data tons of measured
data from many different ecommerce sites
if you stall when people are looking at
their shopping cart they leave they just
go go clean the kitchen right they don't
stay right if you give them the wrong
value in the cart because it's an old
value of the cart then they fix it
they stay and so it's big big big
business difference you want to have
that shopping cart even if it's wrong to
be presented there and you can do
additions and subtractions to the
shopping cart in a way which settles out
there eventually consistent if you do
the multiple things you can fix it up
shopping carts must be right now even if
they're not right so that whole tension
do you want it right or do you want it
right now we don't talk enough about it
right that's a huge issue it's
measurably better for the business to
show the wrong result promptly
measurably better measurably happier
customers measurably better right and so
users are asked to verify the cart
before completing in a nonlinear risible
stores sometimes old versions of the
cart exist in the version history
directed acyclic graph items are added
deleted relatively simple cart semantics
can clean the mess up if there's
divergent versions so you have low
latency predictable reads low latency
predictable writes yes read your rights
no I'll give you the wrong answer but
I'll be I'll be at ya real fast and it's
all good
ecommerce product catalog feeds and
crawls processed by the back end so you
see literally millions of people selling
stuff in tens and hundreds of millions
of products on some of these big
ecommerce sites they feed things in
describing the products there's people
crawling the web to go to manufacturers
sites to go and pull stuff out to get
the descriptions of the vacuum cleaner
that's going to be sold and formatting
it in a consistent way to fit into the
e-commerce website so data from webs and
from partners produces distilled product
descriptions each product has a unique
identifier the identifier takes you to a
partition the partition takes you to a
replica via load-balancing
the replica in that code for the product
unique identifier takes you to the
product description if you need more
products you make more shards
horizontally if you need more read
traffic you stack more vertically okay
so back-end processing and pub/sub are
throughput
sensitive for the most part it doesn't
matter if it takes one second or an hour
to get the product description updated
it matters that the aggregate amount of
junk you're processing can get stuffed
out into those caches right latency is
not important different replicas may be
updated a sync user catalog lookup is
latency sensitive scale is important
it's okay to get a stale version of the
product so what do I have here I have
low latency predictable reads yes low
latency right uh-huh read your rights
uh-uh this is just an example of where I
don't care about that I don't care if I
get the old description of the vacuum
cleaner on one read and then the new
description on the next street it's like
okay the world didn't end
and so that's got a lot to do with the
semantics of the identity of the vacuum
cleaner in the description I'm not doing
joins across it the way I am in the
generalized relational database is a
different critter so lots of scale
search web crawlers feed search indexers
very similar to the product catalog I'm
crawling the web I do the search
indexing I'm charting it I'm putting
these into and you know engrams that I'm
searching and I push them out of the
indices of the search request can come
updates to the index are not super
latency sensitive it's not 100% true the
high-end search things like Google and
Bing and so forth have parallel
high-speed response things for latest
news breaking things if there's been a
big event that's happened in the world
but for the most part everything is
happening kind of in the slow boat right
getting it there very important that
search requests get low latency retries
to other servers in a shard are okay as
long as the latency is bounded so in
search instead of hitting one of those
shards I have to hit all of them and
then aggregate it and so if one of those
call
slow I'm in trouble right it slows me
down a lot there's to me one of the
handful of best papers to have a systems
person read a system student read is
Taylor scale by Jeff Dean and Luis
Barroso and communications of the ACM
it's amazing right the broad idea is if
you call one of those server one of
those shards and one of those servers if
you call that and it takes too darn long
okay then what you do is you say if it's
more than 95th percentile like 19 out of
20 requests is faster than this one's
taking I'm gonna say to heck with it and
I retry to another replica in the same
shard so I can get an answer from all
the shards now the 99.9% I'll answer is
dramatically lower and there's just
amazingly cool descriptions that happen
then and that paper is just essential
for any systems you know computer
science person so low latency
predictable reads yeah low latency
predictable writes oh not in general
read your rights nope this is all
jittery and flaky and crazy
lots of scale big data appending to big
files
okay so HDFS dedupe have big data each
byte offset is assigned a form of
linearize ability of the append the
question is who's giving the semantics
the appends will usually be very fast
but be delayed appends can be delayed
while the system copes with sickness or
death the Arita big data can bound the
SLA and so the issue is rights don't
matter a lot in a batch system and the
reads can retry to another replica and
so in this system because it's batch you
care much more about aggregate
throughput if one out of a hundred
requests is slow that's fine if the
other 99 are fast enough to make up for
it which is different than when there's
a human being waiting for the answer and
so it's different than where I need all
all of the shards of the search index
because I have to have all of them come
back together and I need to get that
that human interaction SLA conclusion
conclusion is it's about the application
pattern low latency reads writes read
your rights care for replacement
has to work across multiple key values I
need to read my rights I will take the
stalls or because I'll get a mess if I'm
doing something like a work flow I'll
get a mess if I don't if I get a stale
answer blobs by ref because they're
immutable I can have not only resonable
and immutable and it's like phenomenal
right there are other examples of that
immutable that are phenomenal ecommerce
shopping cart it's actually okay to give
the wrong answer and so I just need it
fast product catalog the same thing I
want to i want my reads fast from the
product catalog search I want my reads
fast that's the thing that matters
append to big files I can get my reads
fast I'm not that worried about the
rights the data is immutable and so I
think there's interesting work that we
can do with this area it's it's actually
the order of the write that is the
fulcrum of the indecision so I wrote a
paper called standing on the distributed
shoulders of giants which is poking fun
at physicists and one of them is
Heisenberg was on the right track one of
the sections WR ite and the point is you
can know where you write or you can know
when you write but you can't know both
in order to solve that the identity of
the order needs to be assigned at the
client that's writing and so which is it
all tangled up in this stuff so
linearize ability and read your rights
are not always required in modern
scalable apps how you use your state
depends on your app requirements so I
always tell everybody including students
especially students when you're doing a
presentation you start with the
takeaways and it takes me one to two
hours to write a typical takeaway slide
just one stinkin slide and I'm always
revisiting and I'm always going over you
know blah blah blah so this is what I
hope you remember this is what I started
out to write okay
state means different things session
state stateful sessions remember stuff
stateless doesn't remember on the
session durable stuff stuff is
remembered when you come back later even
after failures most scalable computing
comprises micro services with stateless
interfaces they're great they have
partitioning failures rolling upgrade
stateful sessions are problematic
microservices make all other
microservices to read data and get stuff
done but it's the composition of this is
kind of hard right and figuring out how
to make it predictable transactions
across stateless calls usually aren't
supported in micro service solutions
Micra services means no server-side
session state which means no
transactions across calls which means no
transactions across objects there you go
so this is what you're getting is part
of the package deal with micro services
coordinated changes use the careful
replacement technique it's the same
technique from computing early days we
see it all over the stack it's you know
deja vu all over again
each update provides new versions of the
stuff with a single identity complex
content within the new version may
include many things including outgoing
and incoming messages that complex
content of you know app defined messages
in tending to be sent is very powerful
very powerful different applications
demand different behavior from durable
state do you want it right for example
read your rights or do you want it right
now with bounded and fast SLA that's to
me it's just a big deal right humans
usually prefer right now - right
sometimes they care to stall to get the
right answer the correct answer but
usually they just want right now even if
it's not perfect many app solutions are
based upon object identity may be
tolerant of stale versions and immutable
objects can provide the best of both
world by being right and right now
that's it I got some time thank you
the question is why wire is right now
better for humans as an app designer as
a builder of a system you have to think
that through and try to empathize with
what your humans are going to do mostly
though most cases I can work around to
finding a right now answer that people
are pretty happy with
it's it's kind of crazy it's it's but it
works that way yes yes right now when
people repeat they ask again yeah they
do
they repeating they ask again but it's I
mean what do you do if you get the wrong
if you if you look at your shopping cart
native snoc right what do you do you fix
it a lot of times when you go to buy you
do when you go to push the thing that
you review it and then you say and they
say wait what happened that I added that
thing we're okay I'll add it again sure
it's what people do but if if this thing
just locks up and says no I'm spinning
you know the little wheel would go do
the dishes
where you at tend them when they switch
to the center food banks and secure
stuff but going to the no no so much
that no I'd left in 1990 okay Dan it was
an interesting box though yeah
interesting variation yes yes did this
kind of hang together to make sense
terms promote fairness yeah chart with
yeses and noes in various columns are
there are there plus work terms for for
various combinations not that I know of
this is me making this stuff up well I'm
surprises that was my commercial my
question I'm surprised you haven't used
the database convention of the acronym
asset well first I love acid I mean and
I'm just so it is the the description in
inconsistence a little weak but most of
those terms are very strong and it
describes how does the transaction talk
about the sequence of of transactional
behavior which basically the goal is to
make it look like nothing else is
happening when you're doing your work in
a single transaction everything else
happens before or after and that is that
the technical concept for that is called
serializability as and I could create a
serial order
doesn't mean it is serial it means it
could be serial and so I just in writing
down observations is this is you know to
me I just think about random junk and
try to write it down and I realize that
this is not completely well formed but I
have a day job building systems and this
is recreation it is honestly just stuff
I do on the side to them to that day
well thank you it's just the weekend
there are reports some of the big
medical wonderful computer systems can't
handle daylight savings time changes
what the tandem do for time in Toronto
I don't recall at the same time he says
there wasn't typically patient data
you're correct it was building stuff yes
they were using time instead of its
entire you know they've been around for
more than 30 years ago so there is no
generic
I think we're still so the question is
does it advocate for having a single
storage that can do all of this stuff
and my instinct right now is no that
doesn't mean overtime as an industry we
don't learn um I think better
discussions about the trade-offs or what
I would want to start with if you
understand where I'm what I'm saying
with that and I haven't seen single
solutions that are at panacea I think
you could build some of these semantics
for these single solution you know on
top of it a single infrastructure if you
wanted that maybe give you backup and ER
and some disaster recovery but I don't
know I'm thought about it enough I on a
hole where I think the issue is that's
very complicated is people are rushing
to micro services for good reason for
good reason and mostly they don't know
what they're getting into
that's just my to me that's the more
important thing is so they'll pick us
they'll pick us door that doesn't work
for that and they'll have expectations
for other apps going to compose without
thinking about that transactions and
databases have been so successful that
we've kind of lost the skill set to deal
with the funky behavior of random
systems because it Cottard it called the
app developer and and so the the
challenge is women wearing how do we
have higher level abstractions that
still coddle the app developer I'm a
believer in that by the way I'm a big
believer in platforms when I was young
it was the the TP monitor and that was
how do I manage four hundred terminals
when they have to run through one
process and the guy who wants to work
guy or gal who wants to program for an
insurance company doesn't want to think
about asynchronous management of the
messages from the terminals so that was
phenomenal right now we're trying to do
this at cloud scale this is why i
targeted salesforce it's a fascinating
company with a great bunch of good stuff
but it's about making it easy for people
to build their solutions in the cloud
nobody else does that in the cloud now
the ways in which that works income
combining databases and combining
the micro services and growing solutions
that way I don't think we have a really
good guidance for everyone yet did that
make sense and it's gonna be fun hey
it's been I've been doing this for 40
years it's been a great ride I'm looking
forward to do it for a lot more years
it's just a hoot so yes I'm sorry this
just one sec you know shows is there
still trade up seem to pay attention to
there are still four different
application use cases but what's changed
think about you were here decoration
that candle at the beginning as you said
it used to be that you had a whole team
of specialists to to develop a system
and application works or whatever it is
much more democratized in the sense of
now anybody probably not know about some
of these trade offs and they may not
even have a computer science reference
so yes by the pressure point that I was
speaking about the fandom happened in
the 90s okay where it was just Eunice
and you can just go down the street buy
something that did your your needs met
your needs and ran on UNIX you installed
it without hiring programmers but then
that changed over time under scale and
distribution and mobile devices and the
list goes on and so that's grown the
complexity of the standard ly accepted
app is grown by making sense right now
that's true right but I guess my point
was it's it's much more possible now for
someone with far less training
understanding these these trade-offs and
so forth to build an app that mean we're
now you know so the I think it comes
back to what you're just saying that
then you can't expect that the designer
of this system is necessarily going to
have the background to be able to take
all of these crappy shoes in so does
iteration so the thing I mentioned about
for my loving platforms right the
platform's happened like transaction TP
monitor platforms and and cloud-based
platforms and is and so forth have have
happened because someone looks around
and people are solving junk in ways that
are one-off and then they're saying oh
this is a pattern for how people are
building their application but they're
doing it this way versus this over there
and they say wait I'm gonna make it this
so that there's this bear this interface
this abstraction this platform and if
you will platform as-a-service right
that does these things and they don't
have to think about a lot of stuff right
in you know sales first is just a
phenomenal job of masking multi-tenancy
so we're sharing very expensive
resources across many many many
concurrent tenants and making it so that
the customers don't have to worry about
that and that's a phenomenal platform as
a service and but as the applications
grow as big data grows as data science
grows there's all these new cool things
go I look forward to seeing how those
are made more approachable to folks who
don't have PhDs in computer science that
to me is the fun that's the real fun did
I answer your question okay
did you tomorrow tomorrow sorry or
something if I took a simple server and
just a simple server
what's the sort of resource cost I don't
care is much higher the opportunity and
there's no one answer to that I mean
when I was in tandem in the early days
we were neurotically checkpointing every
write across computers and and they were
doing you get a computer and it would do
that was the guy who was doing the data
would would send a check point to the
other say yes now you can do that right
it was fine and then we started using
log based techniques to do it once and
that it would be secretly
go over it it was much faster and then
we had to change the transaction
semantics so that if they blew then it
would clean it up and all of that was a
great improvement cuz it didn't modify
what the programmer saw the programmer
saw a transparent behavior out of the
app but we made less work happen these
things are gonna happen at so many
different areas so I don't have a way to
answer your question without us getting
into a far more detailed discussion of
what the work is interesting but it but
you get in general you make it slow and
then you make it fast I mean one of my
cynical comments is that when you're
releasing software there's two kinds of
releases there's performance releases
and there's anti performance releases
and you make this new feature and it
goes slower and then you make it go
faster it that happens a lot so it's
just a lot of these new things are how
do I lower the barrier to entry for the
developer that's kind of the key point
at this point yeah or but slower and
more functional and right there's a
bunch of reasons you do it and there's a
bunch of reasons that happen and then
once the performance is improved the
aggregate performance is usually wait
the heck better because you worked at it
and a few things are a little slower
here and there and that's just natural
that's the way things work I understand
sounds funny how many people thank you
guys thank you
you